[Música]
en 2005 comprendí el valor de una hoja
en blanco mi vida era cómoda tenía yo
pues además de mucho amor de mi familia
un esposo maravilloso que siendo campeón
íbamos a viajes increíbles pero 2005
marcó mi vida porque ahí comprendí cuál
es el dolor tan profundo la vida
destrozada de una niña que es víctima de
la trata de personas
carla de 12 años fue captada por un
tratante de tlaxcala un hombre sin
escrúpulos que teniendo 10 años más que
ella la enamoró era una pequeñita de tan
solo 12 años cuando después de todo lo
que sufrió en su propia familia porque
venía de un hogar con violencia donde a
los 5 años fue y fue de los 5 a los 12
años abusada sexualmente y escapando de
esa realidad conoce a este tipo que le
enamora que la convence y que después de
tres meses de prometerle el cielo el sol
y las estrellas la comienza a prostituir
a los 12 años en una casa de citas en
jalisco ella sufre las peores vejaciones
que un ser humano pueda vivir llorando
pidiendo clemencia tantos clientes
un día cuando ya había pasado esta
pesadilla porque fue de los 12 a los 16
años hizo cuentas para saber cuántas
veces un hombre la compró siendo sólo
una niña más de 40 mil bestias
compraron ese cuerpecito de una niña
pequeña sin ver sus lágrimas sin ver su
belleza
carla hoy
tiene una hoja en blanco pero tantas y
tantas no 70.000 niños y niñas en esta
nación están viviendo lo que carla
explotación sexual niños y niñas que
están desde bebés siendo explotados para
la pornografía infantil para ser
vendidos en estos lugares donde en la
merced en sullivan en tijuana en tantos
lugares donde vienen aún extranjeros a
comprar a nuestros niños y niñas ellos
no tienen una hoja en blanco esos niños
y niñas además pasan a ser adultos y
vemos zonas donde vemos adultas dice la
fundación se les de francia que más de
500.000 niños pasaron a ser adultas y el
90% créanmelo lo he comprobado
personalmente el 90% de lo que parece
prostitución es trata de personas
que empezaron como carla
que están hoy sin el derecho a tener una
hoja en blanco
por eso cuando yo estuve en washington
la primera vez en 2005 y me capacitan y
veo un documental de una niñita solo era
un documental no había conocido a nadie
una niñita que también fue llevado a
otra nación para vivir este infierno
cuando estoy ahí escucho que al final se
quita la vida
todavía lo recuerdo y me duele el alma y
se me atora realmente en la garganta
porque desde entonces no pude dormir
tranquila no podían voltear mi rostro y
decir no lo sé porque todos y todas los
que conocen esta realidad y el dolor de
una víctima de trata no pueden si son
humanos no pueden dejar de hacer algo
ahí me comprometí a que abriríamos el
primer refugio el primer refugio es a
donde llegó car la fundación camino a
casa esa es la manera de darles una hoja
en blanco de darles la posibilidad en
esa hoja en blanco de escribir un libro
de los sueños cuando su proyecto de vida
está totalmente destruido ellas
necesitan una hoja en blanco necesitan
volver a pensar que su vida tiene futuro
que si pueden vivir que no tienen que
quitarse la vida
carla fue de las que llegó más agresivas
la mayoría llegan deprimidas
carla nos querían matar a todos golpeaba
a las paredes quería golpear al abogado
quería golpearme a mí
fue muy duro para ella y hoy tristemente
en esta nación solo seis estados de la
república tienen refugios los demás no
tienen esa posibilidad necesitamos 32
refugios para que personas como carla
tengan esa posibilidad de escribir una
nueva historia
nosotros estamos luchando todos los días
para que además ellas puedan realmente
salir de esa vulnerabilidad sabes la
mitad del país es vulnerable a la trata
de personas
la fundación watch free desde australia
dice que méxico el 57 punto 31 por
ciento de las personas que viven en
méxico pueden caer en redes se trata
porque no discrimina no es un tema nada
más de niñas no es un tema nada más de
mujeres trata es laboral también es
trabajos forzados puede ser también
tráfico de órganos
lo mismo que adopciones falsas la mitad
del país puede caer en estas redes y
entonces qué podemos hacer tú y yo
la vulnerabilidad tiene que ver como lo
explico siempre en un árbol de la trata
de personas si tú ves este árbol las
raíces por la que la gente cae porque
buscaron a carla por su situación de
desintegración familiar porque había
pobreza en su hogar porque a veces hay
adicciones y con eso te logran tener en
un giro negro y dices por qué no escapa
porque está aquí esta mujer porque hay
cadenas invisibles porque todo esto que
les hace vulnerable el bajo nivel
educativo la violencia produce un fruto
y un fruto de muerte en la trata de
personas todos los lugares donde
permiten que éstos estas zonas crezcan
donde hay giros negros crece alrededor
todo tipo de situación que no queremos
en nuestra nación como por ejemplo si
logran llevar a un ministerio público a
un policía a donde está una niña como
carla
ella le pasó personas uniformadas la
violaban ella pensaba que llegaban a
salvarla y lo único que llegaban es a
violarla y además a grabarla con su
celular
pero cuando estas autoridades a ellos
los graban o les sacan una foto se acabó
tenemos esas autoridades del lado del
crimen alrededor crece todo crece el
secuestro el narco muchas de las
víctimas el dolor de ser violadas además
sirve para alimentar otros delitos por
eso lo que necesitamos si la mitad del
país es vulnerable a la trata es que tú
y yo le demos la mano a la otra mitad
del país darles una hoja en blanco tú y
yo eso es lo que hemos llamado a la
campaña corazones unidos la onu tiene
una campaña de corazón azul pero le
decía yo a los amigos de la onu saben
ustedes por todos lados andan clamando
aquí estoy dicen las víctimas pero quien
les da la mano quien les da la
posibilidad de una hoja en blanco
la mitad del país tiene oportunidades
podría tomar una vida y ayudarla hasta
que salga adelante sabes sólo el 2% de
las víctimas de trata logran sobrevivir
como carla sólo es el 1% sabes por qué
se salvó sacarla porque los de todos
estos son bestias que la violaban un
hombre solo 1 jose calvario becerra vio
la belleza de una niña
pagaba para hablar con ella no la tocaba
un año y medio estuvo luchando hasta que
carla entendió que podía tener una hoja
en blanco que podía salir adelante le
ayudó aún a recuperar a su bebita porque
los tratantes le quitaron a la nena para
tenerla y esclavizar la son estas
cadenas invisibles pero un año no vio a
su hija y jose calvario becerra él ayudó
a rescatar esa niña
podemos dar la mano pero sabes es
difícil en el círculo virtuoso donde yo
explico lo difícil que es que una
víctima pueda recuperarse porque no
solamente es el refugio que fue lo
primero que hicimos después necesitan
terapias necesitan la ayuda de las
autoridades y la ayuda de la sociedad
civil necesitan pasar por reparación del
daño por tener una carrera para que
ellas se fortalezcan y no solamente
sobrevivan porque siempre estarán en
riesgo seguirán siendo vulnerables
necesitan llegar al punto que tú y yo
podamos admirar las y ver en ellas esas
mujeres valiosas que siempre fueron lo
que llamamos supervivientes cuando ya
tienen un proyecto de vida y no
solamente piensan en ellas mismas no
sólo están en el área de confort que
ahora pueden tener sino ahora
tienen la posibilidad de darle una hoja
en blanco
yo me siento tan orgullosa de carla
porque carles una mujer que salió
adelante y hoy ayuda a muchas mujeres
dentro de pronto va a otro viaje porque
ha tenido muchos viajes he estado ante
los alcaldes y gobernadores con el papá
francisco ha estado varias veces en
eventos con él ante la reina noor de
jordania con la duquesa de cornwall ha
hablado en el congreso de los eeuu es
una de las mujeres de las que en méxico
debería de sentirse más orgullosos y
sabes yo te pido si tú quieres que
podemos todos hacer algo por una persona
si tú pudieras hoy decidir voy a salir
de mi comodidad para darle la mano a una
persona vulnerable para que no caiga en
las redes de trata voy a ayudar a
alguien hasta que esa persona pueda
ayudar a otro si tú decides hacerlo
porque no te pones de pie levantas esa
hoja mientras le damos la bienvenida a
carla jacinto de la cual méxico debería
hoy sentirse orgullosa
gracias carla por estar aquí con
nosotros yo quisiera pues que juntas
invitamos a toda la gente a levantar su
hoja si va a ayudar a otro ser humano
muchas gracias de verdad méxico necesita
eso no va a cambiar de otra manera hasta
que tú hasta que yo ayudemos a una
persona el tiempo que sea necesario para
que ella como hoy carla ayudas a tantas
personas gracias por todo lo que haces
por la nación
[Aplausos]
[Música]